por octavo día Francia vivió una jornada
de huelgas y protestas en contra de la
Reforma de pensiones propuesta por el
gobierno de Manuel macron la cual Busca
entre otros puntos aumentar la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años causando una
gran indignación popular vamos a llegar
hasta el final no podemos dejarla pasar
llevo 38 años trabajando en las
alcantarillas es imposible entonces
entiéndelo Seguiremos y Seguiremos hasta
el final hasta que tengamos la reforma
de pensiones
varias refinerías no están operando las
centrales energéticas de todo el país
redujeron su producción mientras que los
recolectores de basura y los barrenderos
han dejado de trabajar porque temen
perder privilegios especiales con los
posibles cambios de la ley la reforma
pensional se aplicaría de forma
progresiva hasta 2030 alcanzando los 64
años para la edad de jubilación poniendo
hacia Francia en una postura similar que
la de la mayoría de los países europeos
con un promedio de edad de jubilación de
65 años o más
el gobierno asegura que el aumento es
crucial para evitar el colapso del
sistema y garantizar que las poblaciones
más jóvenes no asuman la carga de
financiar a las generaciones mayores
este camino debe llevarnos a un paso
importante para nuestro país un paso
necesario como saben por la evolución
demográfica la población francesa está
envejeciendo y por lo tanto hay menos
personas cotizando hoy en el sistema en
comparación con el número de
pensionistas
ahora el futuro de la Reforma dependerá
de las coaliciones que logre encontrar
macron un panorama retador luego de
perder la mayoría en las elecciones del
año pasado por lo que se necesita el
apoyo de los conservadores para sacar
adelante su plan
[Música]